We're traveling through a beautiful but dangerous
region.
Near the South Sudanese border in the impoverished
lowland of Ethiopia lies Gambela: a hotbed
of conflicts among different ethnic groups.
Behind that's South Sudan, a young, independent
nation.
But the fighting there continues.
More than two million people have fled to
neighboring countries like Ethiopia.
This country produces hundreds of thousands
of displaced people itself – due to ethnic
clashes, drought and flooding.
So what’s the perspective for refugees here?
Ethiopia has become Africa’s second largest
refugee-hosting country.
In the Gambela region, refugees number almost
as many as Ethiopians: about 400 thousand.
This camp is home to 60 thousand traumatized
refugees who fled fighting in South Sudan.
“When the war erupted in South Sudan, children
were set on fire, and many others were abducted.
The soldiers even killed blind people.
People were forced to eat dead bodies and
have sexual intercourse with family members.
Boys were forced to have sex with their mothers.
This trauma will not be forgotten.”
Ruey and her family feels safe in this camp.
It's supposed to be a “temporary” home
– but they've been here four years already.
Without permission to work outside the camp,
she fears the future looks dim.
“When my husband was in South Sudan he had
a job, but now he doesn’t.
This is a problem because we depend on aid.
Lack of education is also a problem.
I want education for my children and for myself.
Only then will we have a chance here in Ethiopia.”
That's just one of the problems in the camp
run by the UN and the Ethiopian government.
“When you compare the number of refugees
with the service, it is less than the standards
set out by the UN commission for refugees.
More people means less resources.
We are only providing basics, which is life
saving service.”
Food?
Yes.
Food and water.
Outside the camp, there are mixed feelings
among the local population.
Ethiopia's ethnic Nuer are more welcoming
of refugees because many arriving from South Sudan
are from the same group.
But Ethiopia's ethnic Anuak say they feel
threatened.
“Many of these refugees come from South
Sudan.
They're straining our resources.
We are getting poorer, so the government should
help us, too.
If not, there could be clashes with the refugees.”
Here in Gambela city, the new Prime Minister
Abiy Ahmed has promised opportunities for
everyone -- refugees AND locals.
But unemployment is very high in the region,
especially among young people.
“We don't see any improvement regarding
the youth.
There are no jobs.
We're trying to get ahead on our own, but
we don’t get very far.”
Playing pool costs 5 birr, or 20 US cents.
It's the only form of entertainment these youth can afford.
The lack of prospects drove Ethiopians to the streets to demand jobs last year.
If employment prospects aren't forthcoming soon,
existing tensions over land and ethnicity could boil over.